even the streets outside the university
complex have been utterly trashed in the
violence here bricks broken glass and
barricades led us to the main steps to
the university building
after days of pandemonium and noise it's
eerily quiet now there are no police
inside the main entrance to the
Polytechnic is pretty much destroyed
tables littered with unknown Molotov
cocktails
the pro-democracy demonstrators felt
they could hold out against the police
in truth surrounded and trapped their
resolve
Abdo way
only the hardiest and the most scared to
leave stay behind
inside small groups of protestors
wandered around they didn't want to be
filmed
they're still looking for a way out but
apart from a few escapes
they're now realizing that they're
simply nowhere to go
tom is waiting for his lawyer to take
him out he knows he's going to get
arrested the punishment could be very
severe will you'll be in prison for a
while do you think if they don't have
the evidence to charge me I think I
don't I won't get into jail but if they
have the evidence the longest year is
not ten years yeah ten years it's a very
long time room after room home to the
sit in and out empty and there's a huge
amount of damage as well as the police
neared as the barricades were set on
fire the college campus itself became
the target of the protests but inside
some still believe they can survive to
fight another day this is an enormous
university with lots of different blocks
and some of the protesters we've spoken
to saying that there is a hardcore
perhaps as many as a hundred who aren't
just still here but are actually hiding
in some of these buildings and intend to
try and hide for the whole period even
if the police come looking for them
they're going to try and tough it out
but they've got virtually no food and no
water but they don't want to get
arrested and face ten years in prison on
the outer edges of the university
building the police cordon is getting
tighter
any movement tracked by their powerful
torches
inside specialist fire and rescue
officers are carrying out search patrols
in the university halls
negotiators and medics looking after
those who realize that they have no
choice but to give themselves up some
are treated in the midst of the damaged
compound
others some suffering from hypothermia
had gathered together their gold foil
blankets in stark contrast to the broken
campus around them
they like over a thousand or for them
are then led away through the broken
barriers and then handed over to the
police and taken away
the protests in Hong Kong goes on of
course just not here anymore Stu around
see Sky News Hong Kong